in this lesson we're going to talk about
logarithms often referred to as logs
we're going to talk about how to switch
between the logarithmic form and the
exponential form as well as the
properties of logs whether you're
expanding or condensing so let's get
right into this lesson the first thing
is you can see a log it's got the
logarithm it's got the base it has the
argument and then it has the answer here
and what you want to do is you want to
remember how to switch between the log
form and exponent form the way you would
do that is you would
exponentiate
both sides because exponential functions
and logarithmic functions if you
remember they're inverses of one another
they undo one another so by raising both
sides using the same base here in this
logarithm these are going to undo one
another or cancel each other out and we
then have x equals b to the n it'll be a
little bit easier to solve from there so
an example would be like
if we have log base 3 of 1 9 equals x
we can exponentiate or raise both sides
using base 3.
3 to what power is 1 9 that's going to
be 3 to the negative 2 so the answer is
going to be negative 2. 3 squared is 9
and the negative takes the reciprocal
so that's how you switch the forms you
just instead of taking the log base b
you exponentiate both sides using base b
and that switches forms now the other
thing you want to remember or recall i
should say
is knowing how to expand logarithms okay
and condense logarithms and these are
the properties you want to memorize so
if you have log of a product see these
two things multiplied together you can
write it as the sum
of the two logs okay it's two logs i
should say and if you have the sum of
two logs you can combine them into log
of the product of these two arguments x
times y okay when you divide you can
write it as a difference of two logs
okay log of the numerator minus log of
the denominator and then if you have log
of a
you know something raised to a power you
can bring that power down in front as a
coefficient now if you were condensing
you would bring that coefficient back up
as a power same thing here if you're
subtracting then you would divide these
arguments combine them into one log and
if you're adding you would multiply
and combine them into one log so let's
look at some examples see if you
remember how to do these and we'll go
through them together so example one it
says solve for x log base 7 of x equals
2
and they give us the answers a b c and d
so go ahead and do this on your own
we'll go through it together
okay so the first thing i'm going to do
is i'm just going to do the inverse of
log base 7 i'm going to exponentiate
using the base 7. these are inverses
they cancel one another out x equals 7
squared which is 49 so you can see the
answer is going to be letter d
now for example 2 it says if log base b
of x equals c and log base b of y equals
d what does log base b of x divided by y
the quantity squared equal in terms of c
and d so see if you can do this one on
your own
but what i'm going to do here is i'm
going to bring this 2 down in front of
the log so that's 2
log base b
of x divided by y now when we divide
remember we subtract the logs so this is
going to be log base b of x minus log
base b of y
the whole thing multiplied by 2 but they
tell us that log base b of x is equal to
c and the log base b of y is equal to d
so what we have is we have 2 times c
minus d or you could distribute and say
2c minus 2d
so
definitely knowing how to work with
logarithms is going to be helpful when
you're preparing for the act go ahead
and review this lesson if you need to
and i'll see in the next lesson